>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE ARE IN MUSIC CITY NASHVILLE,
TENNESSEE.
THE SIGHT OF THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION AND THEIR
SPRING CONFERENCE.
WE WILL HAVE AN OPEN DISCUSSION
WITH SIX OF THE NATION'S TOP
GOVERNORS ABOUT THE STATE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
WE WILL TAKE ON IMMIGRATION AND
TALK ABOUT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND TAXES AND LAW AND ORDER.
WHAT POLICIES WORK FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT.
IT'S SIMPLE.
LIBERTY AND 1ST AND 2ND
AMENDMENT.
LOW TAXES.
CHOICE FOR OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL.
WE NEED INTEGRITY IN ELECTIONS.
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION AND
PARTISAN OBSERVERS AND SECURE
BORDERS.
WE BELIEVE IN FREE MARKET
SOLUTION FOR HEALTHCARE WHILE
PROTECTING PEOPLE WITH
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS.
WE BELIEVE IN LAW AND ORDER.
WITHOUT IT, YOU CAN'T PURSUE
HAPPINESS.
FREE AND FAIR TRADE AND PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH.
FOR ME THAT SUMS IT UP.
HOPEFULLY THE GOVERNORS WILL
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN WORKING
IN THEIR STATES.
WE ARE AGAINST CANCEL CULTURE.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
THE BAIL REFORM WHERE YOU GET
ARRESTED AND THEY LET YOU OUT
THE SAME DAY.
HIGH REGULATIONS.
COVID-19 SHUTDOWNS THAT ARE
STILL AFFECTING PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS IN ALLIANCE WITH THE
TEACHERS UNION.
IF SIPPY CUP IS AWAKE WHICH HE
IS LIKELY NOT, THE FASTEST GROW
STATE IS UTAH.
THE FASTEST GROWING STATE IN
SHEER NUMBERS IS TEXAS.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS FLOCKED TO
FLORIDA.
AND OTHER STATES LOST IN THE
2020 CENSUS.
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
KEY ISSUES RELATED TO YOUR
PROSPERITY.
IF REPUBLICANS WANT TO TAKE BACK
POWER IN WASHINGTON, THE AMERICA
FIRST NEEDS TO BE ARTICULATED BY
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO JOINING US
FOR THE HOUR THE NEW HAMPSHIRE
GOVERNOR AND IOWA GOVERNOR.
ARIZONA GOVERNOR IS HERE.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE OF
TENNESSEE THAT IS HOSTING ALL OF
US IS GOVERNOR BILL LEE.
WE ARE JOINED BY A LIVE
AUDIENCE.
YOU ARE FREE TO YELL ANYTHING
YOU WANT.
>> [CHEERING].
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Tucker: WITH ALL OF THAT
SAID, I WILL BE BLUNT AND
HONEST.
I WANT TO GET THE HELL OUT OF
NEW YORK.
I WANT TO SEE WHICH OF YOU WILL
OFFER ME THE BEST DEAL.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Sean: OH.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
I HAVE MY DMV ON STAND BY.
YOU WILL GET A DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND WE WILL REGISTER YOUR VOTE
QUICKL
QUICKLY.
>> Sean: I ALSO LIKE MOUNT
RUSHMORE AND COUNTRY MUSIC.
I WANT TO BE A FARMER.
THE ONLY ONE WHO MIGHT LOSE OUT
IS ARIZONA BECAUSE THE DRY HEAT
IS AWFUL.
THANK YOU ALL.
GOVERNOR, LET'S START WITH YOU.
WE HAVE THIS MASS MIGRATION FROM
BLUE STATES WITH HIGH TAXES AND
REGULATION, DRACONIAN SHUTDOWNS
AND WE HAVE THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS THAT HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT MODELS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT GENERALLY.
>> OUR MODEL YOU CAN SEE OUT ON
BROADWAY.
IT'S OPEN.
OUR BUSINESSES ARE OPEN.
PEOPLE ARE GOING INTO
RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
THERE ARE NOT ANY MASKS.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
A DISTRACTION FOR ALL OF AMERICA
TO SAY THE LEAST.
THE HEALTH CRISIS IS OVER.
THE EMERGENCY IS OVER.
WE HAVE FULLY OPENED UP AND WE
ARE MOVING OUR STATE FORWARD.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE WE FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE.
THE LEFT LIKES TO SAY FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE UNTIL THEY DON'T.
>> Sean: WITH THE VACCINATION
JOE OUTDOORS WALKING INTO JIMMY
CARTER'S HOUSE WITH A MASK ON
AND TAKING IT OFF IN FRONT OF
THE OLD PEOPLE.
THAT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> THEY CAN'T SAY FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE AND WEAR A MASK AFTER
YOU ARE VACCINATED.
THEY CAN'T PUT COVID PATIENTS
BACK IN NURSING HOMES HOME IF
YOU FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
NONE OF YOU DID THAT.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, SOUTH DAKOTA
NEVER SHUT DOWN?
>> NEVER.
WE DID NOT CLOSE A SINGE
BUSINESS EVER.
WE DIDN'T EVEN DEFINE AN
ESSENTIAL BUSINESS.
THE U.S. CONSTITUTION, I DIDN'T
BELIEVE I HAD THE AUTHORITY TO
TELL THEIR BUSINESS WAS NOT
ESSENTIAL.
I TOLD PEOPLE I WOULD TRUST THEM
AND I WOULD LET THEM USE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES AND KEEP
THEIR DOORS AND PROVIDE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS.
THE PEOPLE APPRECIATED IT.
WE NEVER MANDATED MASKS AND WE
HAVE THE FASTEST GROWING GDP IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS 2.8%.
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF JOBS LOST
AND WAGES LOST FROM ANY EMPLOYEE
IN THE COUNTRY.
WE USED CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPLES
WE TALK ABOUT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THEM FOR YEAR.
WE DID THEM.
WE ARE PROVING IT WORKED.
THAT'S THE STORY THEY THINK WE
NEED TO TELL ABOUT 2020.
LEADERSHIP HAS CONSEQUENCES.
YOU LOOK AT DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN STATES.
THEY ARE GROWING AND THRIVING
WHAT ALL OF THESE LEADER DIS.
HOW IT WORKS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE TALK ABOUT STATISTICS AND
FACTS.
BUT THOSE STORIES WILL BE
POWERFUL WHEN WE CHANGE THE
MAJORITY IN WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
CHANGE WHO IS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> Sean: EARLY ON YOU SAID I
TRUST THE PEOPLE OF MY STATE AND
I BELIEVE IN THEM.
IT PAID OFF WELL FOR YOU.
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS, SO FUNNY.
YOU HAVE A ROW WITH YOUR BUDDY
ANDREW CUOMO IN NEW YORK.
I AM LOOKING AT THESE OTHER
STATES, KIDS ARE STILL NOT IN
SCHOOL.
FLORIDA SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPEN
SINCE AUGUST.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THEY ARE
WATCHING YOU DO THIS IT
SUCCESSFULLY AND THEY STILL
DON'T LEARN FROM IT?
>> WELL, IT'S PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST MISTAKE, STRATEGY IS
LOCKING THESE KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL.
THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWING SCIENCE.
THIS IS POLITICS.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
I WAS IN BAKER COUNTY, FLORIDA.
THEY CELEBRATED THE 108th DAY OF
BEING OPEN.
THEY FINISHED THE FULL SCHOOL
YEAR TODAY FROM THE BEGINNING.
EVERY PARENT FROM THE BEGINNING
HAD THE RIGHT TO SEND THEIR KID
TO SCHOOL IN PERSON.
THERE ARE OTHER POLICIES THAT
MATTERED.
WE PREVENTED COVID PATIENTS FROM
BEING SENT TO NURSING HOMES.
I THINK THAT MATTERED.
BUT LOCKING KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL
FOR OVER A YEAR THAT WILL HAVE
RAMIFICATIONS FOR OUR COUNTRY
AND THOSE STATES.
IT WON'T BE DAYS, WEEKS, MONTHS.
IT WILL BE YEARS AND SOME KIDS
WON'T HAVE A FUTURE AS A RESULT
OF THIS BAD POLICY.
>> Sean: THE FIRST INTERVIEW WE
DID, YOU TOLD ME THAT YOU
MOBILIZED EVERY SINGLE STATE
AGENCY IF FLORIDA TO PROTECT THE
ELDERLY, THE OLDER POPULATION IN
YOUR STATE WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT.
>> YES, THE RESULTS ARE 40
STATES HAVE HIGHER PERCAPITA
MORTALITY FOR AGE 65 AND UP
COMPARED TO FLORIDA.
WE PRIORITIZE OUR SENIORS FOR
VACCINATIONS.
THE CDC SAID DO POLITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS.
I SAID NO WAY.
YOU ARE 65 AND UP, WE ARE
GETTING YOU THE VACCINE.
WE HAVE DONE LIKE 4 MILLION
SENIORS.
>> Sean: AND PLACES WERE FREE OF
CHARGE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
COMMUNITY.
>> THAT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
HAD PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NOT SAID
COME UP WITH THIS VACCINE.
IF BIDEN WAS PRESIDENT THIS
WOULD TAKE 4 YEARS.
WE STARTED VACCINATINGING
SENIORS IN DECEMBER.
THOSE WERE LIVES SAVED.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
WARP SPEED, THEY ARE DIRECT
OPPOSITES.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Sean: THE GOVERNORS WON'T BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANYTHING I SAY
AS A TALK SHOW HOST.
A DISCLAIMER.
SENATO
SENATOR, UNRELENTING.
YOU HAD A STATE MODEL.
LIVE FREE OR DIE.
THIS WAS A GREAT BOOK THAT CAME
OUT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> I READ IT COVER TO COVER.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, YOU MADE A
LOT OF THE SAME CHOICES THAT
THESE GOVERNORS MADE.
THE MISTAKES WERE MADE IN NEW
YORK AND NEW JERSEY AND
PENINSULA AND MICHIGAN AND
CALIFORNIA.
HOW IS IT THEY GOT EVERYTHING SO
WRONG AND NOBODY GOT IT PERFECT
BECAUSE IT WAS IMPERFECT.
>> WE WERE WRITING THE PLAYBOOK.
IN NEW ENGLAND WE HAVE ALL OF
THESE STATES THAT ARE TIGHT
TOGETHER.
WE ARE LIKE COUNTIES.
WE HAD TO WORK TOGETHER AS
GOVERNORS.
WE HAD TO CONTEND WITH NEW YORK
AND BOSTON WAS IN TOUGH SHAPE.
CHARLIE BAKER WAS TRYING TO DO
THE BEST HE COULD WITH THE DEATH
RATE IN BOSTON.
WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE.
WE LED THE CHARGE ON THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THE OPPORTUNITY
AND NOW THE ECONOMY.
YOU HAVE 2.EIGHT.
I THINK WE HAVE 2.7.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> EVERY GOVERNOR HAD TO WRITE
THE PLAYBOOK.
YOU HAD TO EARN PUBLIC TRUST IN
THE CRISIS EARLY ON.
DO YOU THAT WITH TRANSPARENCY
AND COMMUNICATION.
WHEN YOU EARN THAT PUBLIC TRUST,
THEY TRUST TO YOU MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS.
>> Sean: I DIDN'T NOTICE OF YOU
WRITING ANY BOOKS TALKING ABOUT
HOW GREAT LEADERS YOU WERE AND
MAKING $5 MILLION.
JUST SAYING.
THEY WANT ME OUT OF NEW YORK.
THIS MATTERS.
THOUGH.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE A LEADER
THE DECISIONS YOU MAKE FOR THE
PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE HARD.
GOVERNOR, I REMEMBER IN IOWA,
THERE WAS A MOMENT, A MEAT
PACKING FACILITY AND THE SAME
THING IN SOUTH DAKOTA.
I WATCHED HOW YOU HANDLED THAT.
IT WAS SPECTACULAR.
YOU WENT RIGHT IN.
FULL COURT PRESS AND SURROUNDED
THE AREA.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> MY FARMERS AND PRODUCERS
PRODUCED OVER 10% OF THE
NATION'S FOOD SUPPLIES.
IT WAS IMPERATIVE TO KEEP OUR
FOOD PROCESSING PLANTS OPEN AND
GROCERY STORES FULL.
WE DID TESTING SO WE COULD NOT
ONLY KEEP THE PROCESSING PLANTS
OPEN, BUT WE COULD ENSURE THE
EMPLOYEES THEY WERE WORKING IN
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
WE PROVIDED THE PPE AND ABLE TO
TEST.
THOSE POSITIVE WERE QUARANTINED
AND WE KEPT OUR PROCESSING
PLANTS UP AND GOING.
WE WERE LOOKING AT HORRIFIC
NUMBERS BECAUSE PROCESSING
PLANTS WERE IMPACTED FROM COVID.
WE MADE TESTING AVAILABLE.
WE IMPLEMENTED A ROBUST DATA
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWED TO US BREAK
DOWN IT BY ZIP CODE AND IDENTIFY
THE POSITIVE CASES AND ACT.
>> Sean: WHEN NEW YORK WAS AT IT
WORST, I SAID ON RADIO AND TV IF
THE MEDICAL MANUFACTURERS AND
FOOD SUPPLIERS, IF THE PACKERS
DIDN'T PACK AND THE TRUCKERS
DIDN'T TRUCK, NEW YORK WOULD
HAVE DIED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU WERE A LIFELINE FOR
PEOPLE IN SIGNIFICANT TROUBLE.
>> AND WE WERE ABLE TO DO IT IN
A RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
WE KEPT THE ECONOMY OPEN.
ALL OF US WERE ABLE TO DO.
THAT WE ARE REAPING BENITIS
TODAY.
WE ARE COMING BACK STRONGER THAN
EVER.
THE NUMBER 1 STATE FOR
OPPORTUNITY IS IOWA.
>> Sean: ISN'T THIS WONDERFUL?
>> WE ALL HAVE OUR STATISTICS,
RIGHT?
>> Sean: COMPARED TO ANY
DEMOCRATS IT'S MUCH BETTER.
GOVERNOR DOOCY.
ARIZONA A LARGE POPULATION OF
OLDER PEOPLE.
YOU HAD CERTAIN CHALLENGES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC.
YOU WERE ABLE TO OVERCOME IT.
HOW?
>> WE FOCUSSED ON THE VULNERABLE
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE KNEW THAT WAS THE OLDER
FOLKS.
WHEN GOVERNOR LEE SAID FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE, IT WAS 65 YEARS AND
OLDER AND PEOPLE WITH UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITIONS.
A CONFERENCE CALL WE WOULD HOLD
AS GOVERNORS WE PRIORITIZED
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS AND
ERRORED ON THE SIDE OF LIMITED
GOVERNMENT.
WE WOULD TRUST OUR CITIZENS.
BELIEVE ARIZONANS HAVE COMMON
SENSE.
IT WAS A TOUGH YEAR.
THERE IS NO WINNER IN THE COVID
YEAR BUT YOU WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING TO COME OUT OF IT
HEALTHIER AND STRONGER.
THAT'S WHERE ARIZONA IS.
LEADING THE COUNTRY IN PERSONAL
INCOME GROWTH.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE DRY HEAT
CHECK OUT FLAGSTAFF, ARIZONA.
>> Sean: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I WAS THERE ONE SUMMER AND I
WALKED OUT AND SAID I CAN'T
BREATHE.
ALL OF YOU HAVE THE PROBLEM THAT
PEOPLE FROM NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY
AND CALIFORNIA AND MICHIGAN,
THEY ARE LEAVING THEIR STATES
AND GOING TO YOUR STATES.
YOU ARE SEEING A HUGE IMPACT OF
MIGRATION OUT OF THE BLUE
STATES.
MY FEAR FOR ALL OF YOU IS THAT
THEY MAY BRING THEIR LIBERAL
POLICIES WITH THEM.
>> WITH FLORIDA.
THE MEDIA AT THE BEGINNING SAID
FLORIDA WAS BAD.
THEY WANTED TO DAMAGE TRUMP AND
ME.
LAST APRIL THEY WERE SAYING
FLORIDA IS DOING WORSE THAN NEW
YORK.
NEW YORK WAS 10 TIMES WORSE.
THE PEOPLE THAT BUY THOSE PHONEY
NARRATIVES FROM THE MEDIA, THEY
PROBABLY ARE NOT COMING TO
FLORIDA.
MOST PEOPLE SEE THROUGH IT AND
THINK LIKE US.
I THINK THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING.
THEY ARE REGISTERING AS
REPUBLICANS AND I HAVE COME
ACROSS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
DEMOCRATS AND LOCKDOWNS TURNED
THEM INTO REPUBLICANS.
THEY SAID I AM IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEY ARE LOCKING MY KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL.
I COME TO FLORIDA THEY ARE IN
SCHOOL AND PEOPLE ARE FREE AND
HAPPY.
I THINK PROCESS CAUSED PEOPLE TO
REEVALUATE PRIOR COMMITMENTS.
IF YOU HAVE A POLITICAL PARTY
THAT PUTS THE INTEREST OF
TEACHER'S UNIONS OVER KIDS
ACCESSING AN EDUCATION, THAT
TELLS YOU ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE MODERN DEMOCRAT PARTY.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
THE ADS YOU WERE RUNNING SAID
COME ON TO SOUTH DAKOTA.
WE OPENLY WELCOME YOU AND
SPECIFICALLY YOU DID THE SAME
THING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE OF SOUTH DAKOTA TO GROW.
YOU ARE ENTICING PEOPLE TO COME.
>> YES.
I RAN FOR GOVERNOR ON THE FACT
THAT I WAS GOING TO BRING THE
NEXT BIG INDUSTRY TO THE STATE
AND GROW THE STATE.
WE WANTED IT TO BE A PLACE WHERE
OUR KIDS GOT OUT OF SCHOOL AND
WANTED TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
THERE.
SURROUNDED BY THE PEOPLE THEY
LOVE.
WHAT WAS INTERESTING IS I RAN ON
SOUTH DAKOTA BEING AN EXAMPLE TO
THE NATION.
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC T
, IT AL
TELL OUR STORY.
THOUSANDS ARE MOVING TO OUR
STATE AND THEY WANT TO LIVE
SOMEWHERE WHERE THE GOVERNMENT
RESPECTS THEM AND SOMEWHERE
WHERE THEY CAN BE FREE.
SOUTH DAKOTA WAS NOT ON THEIR
RADAR A YEAR AGO TO MOVE TO, BUT
IT IS NOW.
THEY WANTED TO LIVE TO HAVE
A QUALITY OF LIFE AND BE
RESPECTED.
WE DID ONE WEEK OF A NATIONAL
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND SAID IF
YOU WANT TO LIVE SOMEWHERE WHERE
YOU ARE SUPPORTED AND PEOPLE
RESPECT YOU AND WE WILL HELP YOU
TAKE CARE OF YOUR FAMILIES, COME
TO SOUTH DAKOTA.
IN ONE WEEK WE HAD HUNDREDS OF
APPLICATIONS FROM 41 DIFFERENT
STATES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SAYING I WANT TO LIVE
THERE.
THEY RESPECT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEY WILL APPRECIATE MY SERVICE.
>> Sean: AND YOU GAVE AN
INCENTIVE.
A BONUS TO EVERYBODY.
TENNESSEE, I LOVE NASHVILLE
BECAUSE I LOVED 90 MILES SOUTH
IN HUNTSVILLE, ALABAMA.
I SEE THE GROWTH.
THE PROPERTY PRICES SOARING WANT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE SOARING.
MUSIC CITY.
USA.
>> CRANES OUT THERE EVERYWHERE.
A LOT HAPPENING.
>> Sean: IT'S FLORIDA, TEXAS AND
THE SOUTH.
I DON'T WANT TO SINGLE THEM ALL
OUT HERE.
THEY ARE ALL GROWING AND
BENEFITING.
WHAT THE KEY COMPONENT, FREEDOM,
LOW TAXES, A NOMINATION?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE LOOKING AROUND
UNSATISFIED IN MANY STATES WITH
LIFE IN PARTICULAR.
LIFE IN THE LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
A LONG TIME, BUT SUDDENLY THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN OUR STATES
AND THOSE BLUE STATES ARE STARK.
THEIR KIDS HAVE BEEN OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR A YEAR.
IN TENNESSEE ALL OF KIDS ARE IN
SCHOOL.
IN FACT WE HAVE A STRONG
SCHOOL --
>> Sean: ARE THEY WEARING MASKS?
>> THEY ARE NOT.
IN A COUPLE OF DISTRICT THEY
ARE.
THE LAW ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO MAKE
THAT DECISION.
I DON'T THINK ANY KID OUGHT TO
WEAR A MASK.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE SCIENCE YOU
DON'T HAVE KIDS WEARING MASKS
WHEN KIDS DON'T GET SICK FROM
COVID-19.
THAT'S SCIENCE.
SCHOOL CHOICES IN STATES LIKE
OUR, PARENTS GET TO CHOOSE.
TENNESSEE IS THE THIRD LOWEST
TAX PER CAPITA STATE.
WE ANNOUNCED 2 MAJOR MOVES
COMPANIES MOVING FROM CALIFORNIA
AND MICHIGAN TO PUT THEIR
LOCATIONS IN THIS STATE.
OUR REGULATION IN THIS STATE IS
REALLY DIFFERENT THAN IN THESE
STATES THAT INCREASED
REGULATIONS.
OUR TAXES WERE REDUCED.
WE CUT TAXES.
THOSE STATES --
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE.
JOE SAID YOU CAN'T TAKE MONEY
AND CUT TAXES.
REALLY?
>> BECAUSE WE OFFER TAX CUTS TO
OUR CITIZENS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THERE IS A COMBINATION --
>> Sean: THIS IS LIKE THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
>> IT IS.
BUT I AM DESCRIBING A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS RIGHT HERE WHO CUT
TAXES AND HAVE LOWER REGULATION
WHO HAVE CHOICES FOR PARENTS,
WHO HAVE A BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT
ATTRACTIVE TO BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHY EVERY ONE OF THESE
STATES AND MINE, U-HAUL MEASURE
TRUCKS GOING IN THAT DON'T GO
OUT AND TENNESSEE IS NUMBER 1.
WE ALL HAVE OUR SATISH KALPOES.
-- STATISTICS.
THERE IS A STARK DIFFERENCE THAT
WE SEE NOW.
>> Sean: VETO TAKE A BREAK.
-- WE HAVE TO TAKE A BREAK.
IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU RENTED
A U-HAUL TO GO TO TEXAS YOU PAY
$250